- On June 12, 2016,
I woke up like any other Sunday morning
and like any other millennial
instinctively checked my phone.
I immediately saw two words splashed
across news outlets and social media,
Orlando and shooting.
My first thought was oh it must be
about the shooting that
happened last week.
So I shrugged, wrap a rainbow
handkerchief around my neck,
and traversed the few blocks
that separated my apartment
from the start of the
Los Angeles Pride Parade.
It was then and there surrounded by a sea
of fellow LGBTQ marchers,
surrounded by family,
that it became common knowledge
that a very similar celebratory crowd
of vibrant young people
had just hours before
been gunned down at Pulse nightclub
in what would be called
the worst mass shooting
in modern US history.
I realized throughout the
following week as my friends
posted eulogies for victims
who they knew in the massacre
that the degrees of separation
between these events
and me don't exist anymore.
In fact, I wondered if
they ever existed at all.
And it dawned on me that the longest,
most influential relationship
I never knew I had
in my life is with mass shootings.
These tragedies have
been brutally effective
in shaping my world view.
So I don't want to speak on this topic
as some self purported expert
like you'll see flooding your feeds,
but from a more sincere,
experiential perspective.
I can remember exactly where
I was and what I was doing
for every major massacre in my lifetime.
And more often than not
the victims and the
perpetrators are around my age.
I am stuck in a cyclical pattern
of abuse in his relationship.
But it wasn't always like this
and it has gotten much, much worse.
When I was five years old,
a man crashed his pickup truck
into a chain restaurant called Luby's
about an hour and half from where I lived
and shot and killed over 20 people.
My father to calm my fears
recounted an infamous school
shooting that had happened
in the 1960s as we drove
passed the Clock Tower
at the University of Texas.
He pointed at it and reassured me
that was the last time
something bad like this
happened around here.
These things don't happen
often so don't be scared.
Little did he know at the time
that he had only lived through
around 20 US mass shootings
before I was born.
By today I have lived
through over 100 and counting
and it all began at Columbine.
I was 13 years old and I
can vividly remember sitting
in front of my television set
in my living room watching the news replay
the scenes of countless students
running out of the school
with their hands on their heads.
Teenagers my age were dangling
from broken windows trying to escape.
Columbine change everything.
And as the adults argued politics
we kids actually went
through a massive tonal shift
when it came to our perspective
on our peers and our culture and security
and that's when I grew paranoid
because our parents had
wars and we had Columbine.
I remember schools
installing metal detectors
at their entrances and I
remember that it became
a common sick practical
joke for some idiot
to call a bomb threat just to
watch everyone get evaluated.
I remember rock music and video games
and even the Internet being blamed.
And if you wore a trench
coat you were a killer.
We were very quick and eager
to turn on one another.
Everyone debated about
who or what was at fault.
And if history has taught us anything
there is no easy answer.
Kids were dead and nothing was done.
And then 9/11 happened
and our generation went
from cautiously skeptical
to absolutely terrified.
Columbine ignited our
fears as young citizens
then 911 defined it to be
rampant, righteous and unending.
And why not? We were scared.
You wanted answers but instead
of reaching for a common goal
we split ourselves in two and
every conversation you had,
every fight online you'll
see in the comments below
and every election year we witness
this endless back-and-forth
as more people die
last resolutions are reached.
Years later while I was
attending film school
at the University of Southern California
I was two weeks away
from publicly premiering
a short film which had already wrapped
when the deadliest attack
at that time happened
on the opposite coast on
a campus much like mine.
And in some twisted sense of timeliness
my short film was a graphic
critique of school shootings.
I remember a mother of one
of my friends walked up to me
and remarked you should
watch what you make
since it looks like your
kind are prone to violence.
Virginia Tech like any other massacre
involving a wide array of players
from different backgrounds
whether it was racial,
religious, cultural,
brought forth and ugliness
that direct affected me
for the first time.
And as we mourned the dead it struck me
that every time that this happens
it not only opens up an opportunity
to advance personal and political agendas,
it becomes top priority
for most of us to do so.
And yet again kids were
dead and nothing was done.
You have Omaha, Binghamton,
Fort Hood twice.
Fort hood in the same town
as that Luby's cafeteria that
was shot up in my childhood.
Schools, malls, churches,
post offices, military bases,
a grocery store parking lot in Tucson.
And then a movie theater in Aurora
during a midnight screening
of The Dark Knight Rises.
Where was I? Waiting to
attend a midnight screening
of The Dark Knight Rises.
We all could have been those victims
excitedly waiting to watch a
blockbuster on opening night.
No one was safe.
And then later that year over 20 people,
the majority being children
on the first grade,
were shot and killed at Sandy Hook,
our little brothers and sisters,
our own children gunned down.
My gut reaction was well now things
will definitely have to change.
But it did not.
Little kids were dead
and nothing was done.
Santa Monica, Santa Barbara,
Marysville, Umpqua, Charleston,
I apologize if I'm forgetting some
but there's just too many to count.
So many that I am becoming so used
to turning from passionate rage
to desensitize resignation on a dime.
I only shrugged. I screamed
and then I shrugged.
And then I forgot.
Our interconnectedness
not only as a nation
but also as an international community.
The Internet, social
media and bullet holes
are like the connected dots
that link our generation
beyond each of the shores.
Paris my second home
where my mother has lived
for over 17 years was hit by a series
of unfathomable terrorist attacks.
And my immediate bleak
thought was my mother is dead.
Thankfully she was unharmed
but we have come to such a
low point as a global society
where we assume the absolute worse
because it's how we already view
one another as human beings.
And then less than a month
later San Bernardino happened
and my mother returned the favor
and had to call me to see if I was okay.
Our entire office on Sunset Boulevard
heard the sirens driving
eastward to San Bernardino
less than an hour away.
In the following week we'd
hold a security meeting
on what to do in an
active shooter situation.
What was once video games and trench coats
has morphed into the red flag dechoir
for politicians who have ensured,
especially with our upcoming election,
that we are a country solely
operating on our fear.
We have let the politicians
and talking heads
and online forums dictate a conversation
that our generation needs to have
about our role in the
fight against violence.
We grew up on these my shootings.
The victims and unfortunately the shooters
are people we all personally know.
Orlando provided a
spotlight on a real issue
this disconnect between
those who write the narrative
and those who are actually living it.
Most of our leaders are
not what the victims were
primarily LGBTQ LatinX, black and young.
In fact many, many a politician
aim to marginalize those groups today.
We are passionate and over-educated,
but desensitized and underrepresented
and thus we become divided
just like the generations before us.
But instead we need to
consider shutting the fuck up
for a second and actually
doing something about it.
The patrons of Pulse were
targeted because of who they were.
They were queer people of color
and US millennials out there all know
and love someone from those backgrounds
and not all politicians do.
It's fine to share their
speeches in your opinions
even about this very video,
but posting in the infinite
soapbox that is the Internet
is like prayer without action.
Contact your elected officials
because eventually we're gonna become
those elected officials.
Some merely shrugging at politics
instead of actively participating in it
will not change the game.
Let's get up all in their business
because if Orlando has taught us anything
it's that they need to know
that we cannot watch
any more of our friends
and love ones die.
And I'll be damned if kids who
are watching this right now
will grow up to be another statistic
because we blindly join a system
that loves to argue about problems
but refuses to produce actual results.
Mass shootings they have been my longest
most intelligible relationship, yes,
but from this moment on it
will be I who defines it.
And when I look back on June 12, 2016,
I want not only remember
the deaths of the innocent,
but what we did to finally make a change.
And finally to the LGBT community
know that you are brave and
that you are strong and loved
and that we are with you.